Hello everyone and welcome to today's
live stream where we have 20 new nodes
to uh look through. So uh some major
things have happened since last time uh
I streamed. Uh the volume nodes got
pulled out of experimental and
apparently like 10 new nodes got added
with new PRs this week. Uh there has
been one I believe community developer I
think the creator of molecular nodes the
add-on I'll need to double check that
who uh basically was really cooking with
the open BDB part and added in a ton of
nodes. So for those of you are wondering
it allows us to do stuff like this. Now
apparently there's another node on the
way called the advect node which might
make it into 5.0 go, which would allow
for just straight up simulations, like
volume simulations.
Uh, but apparently there's a lot of cool
stuff on the way. So, let's get into it.
So, it's all to do with grids, which are
like volumes, but they are quirky, and I
don't fully know how they work yet. I'm
trying to figure that out as we speak.
But grids are kind of like fields, but
they can kind of live differently
compared to fields, and they're kind of
like lists as well. They are quirky and
I do not fully understand them. They're
their own data type, but they can kind
of exist outside of like the regular
geometry flow. So, a lot to go over. So,
let's go and take a look at that.
Actually, I need to get the Blender 5.0
change log up. 5.0 change log. I'll have
that up on the side.
Geometry nodes. So, yeah, geometry
nodes. It there was going to be good
stuff in 5.0 know anyway, but we just
got like a massive amount of stuff.
But yes, let's take a look at this. So,
in the volume section, we got new things
for like get named grid, kind of like
the get named attributes. But this one
is interesting because it takes in a
geometry input and then outputs a grid,
which I was wondering, wait, why is it
not like these uh named attribute node?
But the reason for that, I think, is
because these can just straight up live
separately from the geometry itself,
which is weird and quirky, and I needed
to figure out how that works. Uh, so
yeah, there's that. There's the grid
info, which I think is just like I think
the transform is like the location and
like the scale of it because these can
apparently be sparse potentially. I
don't know. I'm not sure. I'll be saying
that a lot today. and then voxil index
and then like stuff like that. I'm not
sure actually. Let's take a look at the
tool tips. Let's see. Retrieve integer
coordinates of the voxhole that the
field is evaluated on. Oh, so that's for
a field. What? Oh, okay. Okay. Grid info
information about the volume grid. And
then that get a volume grid from a
volume geometry. And then sample grid uh
retrieves values from the grid. sample
grid index grid curl divergence gradient
and lelation. I'm assuming these at the
moment can even do volume simulation,
but the advect one will make it a lot
simpler. Uh, I should also mention Oh,
music is a bit much. Oh, sorry. Dang,
it's so much quieter on my headphones.
Actually, you know what? I'm just going
to lower it in OBS.
I am so sorry, everyone.
There we go. That should be a good
amount better. Uh, sorry about that
everyone. This music will probably get
copyright claimed even though it
shouldn't. So, but this stream is
temporary as well. So, we'll just keep
going and seeing what's going on and see
what goes on. So, yeah, we got store
named grid, set grid background, and set
grid transform. Now, I want to play with
this because this is probably very Oh,
it's a singular value.
Oh.
Huh.
How about that?
Interesting. New toys. Yes, that is what
it feels like. A volume to mesh. Grid to
mesh. Now, people are going to get
confused with the difference between a
volume and a grid. Uh myself included.
Field to grid. Prune grid. Let's see.
Make a storage
tiles or inner nodes. Oh, I'm assuming.
And then there's box. So I assume that
these two are like inverses of each
other. Uh wait
box grid. So one will like make it
sparse and one will make it into even
boxels.
Interesting.
Okay.
Interesting. Very very interesting. Uh,
I guess we can go and test this out a
little bit because with this setup right
here, it takes a volume cube like this
as just a sphere. And then in here, we
get the named grid. We separate it. We
voxalize it cuz it led to some errors
before. Uh, and then we sample the grid
and then we change the field to a grid
while keeping the previous topology. I
know it's weird. And then we store the
named grid. So, it's more complicated
and hopefully we can make node groups
where the user will never have to do
this themselves because that would be a
little bit annoying to do every single
time, but I'm assuming that's 100%
possible.
Uh, okay. So, if I do not voxilize the
grid, we should see some weird artifacts
internally. Yes, right here or here.
It's a bit difficult to see, but here we
can see that that cube is much bigger
than it should be. And I'm assum
actually wait is there a grid to points?
Uh grid to
points. Nope. I Okay, I don't think that
node is in here yet. I saw someone was
working on it. Let's see. Points.
Points to SDF grid. Nope. Uh points to
vertices.
[Music]
Derby points and grid. Nope. Volume
read.
No. H interesting. Uh let me just see
what I can do right here. So here we're
just going to go and manipulate the
value. So a nice multiply right here.
Let's set it to be 10. I just want to
see what's actually going on in there.
there w I think there was going to be a
node where you can turn each of the
voxil
cells into points and get all the data
but I don't think that's in currently
not the most important thing in the
world but it would make debugging this a
little bit easier but yeah we can see
the main grid and then kind of the sub
grids there so if I were to voxalize
that we can see actually wait I can go
and just test this normally
Yeah. Wow, that is interesting. But why
is that? Oh, is this going into the
negatives again?
Yeah, cuz the background is negative
one. So, if I just set that to there.
Oh, it just disappears into the ether.
Okay. Need that to be like at least
negative a little bit. Yes. Okay. So, it
doesn't really like it when it's a
negative background, but it doesn't
fully know how to handle it.
Could try. And no, that wouldn't work.
Yeah, we can see that that's happening.
That looks normal when we do this. It
just does not work as intended. So, you
need to actually voxilize the said grid
for it to work as intended. And right
here, we have a resolution of 75 cubed.
So, and performance seems to be fairly
standard for because all this runs on
the CPU, not the GPU, as expected.
Let's see. But yeah, what can we do
here? So, I want to try a few things
again. Getting and setting the
attributes are still a little bit weird.
Oh, actually, wait a minute. I can just
boxize this beforehand.
Although,
yeah, I know that would work. So, I need
to get it, set it so it doesn't have to
reoxalize every time,
I think. Let's see if this is actually
faster. So if we mute that then let that
run. It runs normally.
I mean it is pretty much exactly the
same. I guess that's good. Or actually
wait what? Oh no that's that is just the
baking going through its course.
Okay so here we are. That's pretty good.
So with this we can eliminate a node. So
we have all that and that is fine.
Let's see what we can do. Actually,
let's attach this right here. Oh, nope.
Let's get the named grid, bring it over
here, check the part right there, and
use the viewer to check the singular
value because we can do that now. So, if
we go into the spreadsheet, 5.0 is
looking pretty good. Let's check the
viewer node. Go to the Where is the
um
Ah, is that one collapsed by default?
Ah, it is. Okay,
we can see that that is Yep.
Interesting. Why is it like that?
I need to think about that because it
has a negative value in the last parts
of the grid.
Let's see. Is that rotation or scale?
I don't know. I forget which parts of
the 4x4 matrix are what. Well, if we set
the grid transform, let's actually try
that.
So, here. Oh, wait. Let me go and bring
this over to H. We can put that there.
Is valid. Intriguing. Most intriguing.
and then we can get it afterwards and
see what happens
right there.
So that yep that's an identity matrix
and no visual changes have occurred
uh because I'm looking at the wrong
thing but there we go. So we can see a
change has occurred which is it just
being completely eliminated.
Um combine transform. So, what are you?
Oh.
Oh,
interesting.
Why do you act like that?
So, this is like setting the scale. Oh,
is the default scale 111?
So, this is 75 m long and such. Oh, that
actually makes a good amount of sense
because that feels like something I
would do. And I've actually tried doing
volumes like this in the past. H.
Then we can move it as well, though. It
seems like uh volume rendering is a bit
funky at the moment.
Unless it's just because part of it is
negative, even though the lowest value
that should exist here is.1,
but that could also happen.
Interesting.
So,
oh wait, I think it just clicked. I
think it just clicked in my brain. What
happens here? So, the geometry here is
No, that doesn't make sense. At least a
grid is a ton of values, a ton of voxels
in space, and then the transform decides
where it is. So, if you have 75 voxels
and you make it fit in a certain space,
it'll just go and compress it.
But what does the geometry line have to
do with this? What does it
Oh, it can hold multiple. Oh, okay. This
can hold multiple grids. That
Okay, I think I think I got it now.
I think I got it now. So, if you have
multiple grids in a geometry, they don't
need to be the same density, the same,
they can be sparse, they can be fully
voxalized and so on. You can just store
as many volumes as you want in a volume
in the geometry line, but the actual
grid itself is that
interesting.
I guess it's almost like instances or
layers in a sense.
Maybe I'll need to I'll need to think
more about that later. And again getting
the voxal index
h
I'm assuming that's the self index. So
the extent
ah okay how many voxels are in one
direction. Yes. I remember making a node
like this for one of my volumeish. It
was just like a point 3D point cloud
that you would just go and sample other
things. But it's nice that we have this
under the hood because that was such a
pain to make.
Dang. Okay, so let's go and try some new
stuff with this node setup that I have.
Uh, first of all, let me go and copy it
so that I don't lose all of my work and
make sure
go that's all defaulted and out of the
way.
So, I want to try getting some velocity
going. Now, this will not work the way I
want to because I don't remember how
divergence actually works.
Um,
let's make
or we can just go and set a grid.
Set grid value.
[Music]
Wait. Uh, set names grid. Okay.
Wait,
what?
Um, oh, store, right?
Uh, let's name this Vel for velocity.
Though again, this will not work the way
I intend, at least on the first five
goes. So, if we store this
here,
what am I missing? Oh, fields. Okay. So,
this is the quirky quirky part about
this.
Uh, okay. So, we have the topology which
is just the form of it. This is very
quirky.
And then we can make that a value.
Give some m
[Music]
Oh, extension sockets are acting a bit
weird with that apparently.
Um
h let us see. Oh, and other news. The uh
attribute transform constraint has been
renamed to the geometry attribute
constraints and might actually make into
5.0. I wasn't too sure for a little
while there, but it seems like one of
the devs um asked around and it can make
it in. It might make it in. I'd say
there's uh a good chance. So, that is
still being worked on
and hopefully it can be it can make it
in. I hope. I really really really hope.
So, let's get Vel right over here. So
yeah, grids are very quirky.
So if we get that and do that.
Oh wait,
ample grid at the position at the
current position.
And that'll be that or no wait, that
needs to be a vector that needs to go
into there. And then that has to go
here. So, we're converting one to the
This is probably going to be mega
inefficient.
Um, but hey, here's to trying it. No, we
don't want that. We want this to be fed
into here. Nope, not that one. That one.
Let's see. Can that possibly work. Looks
like it does. Okay.
And we need to make sure that our
velocity also gets transferred back so
that it updates. And I'm using uh the
nearest neighbor because the other
versions like to lose data. I'm assuming
that's from Divergence or something
along those What the heck? Oh, wait.
That good thing that didn't show the
whole thing cuz I think that was
probably my stream key,
the temporary one. So, no, you cannot
use it to
hack my stream or anything like that.
Okay. Now, does the grid Does this
contain No, it does not contain the
attributes.
So,
if only there was a way to sample a grid
and get all the delicious data from it.
So, if I were to do this, in theory, I
would be able to transfer the color,
the velocity over to there and store it
here.
Hey, now let's go and set a nice
material.
In theory, you're all right here. Please
do not crush my computer. Oh, thank
goodness. Now, this is a new build of
Blender. Uh, all this will probably be
in the next daily build tomorrow, but I
just built it myself because I could
and I like playing with toys as soon as
they come out. Let's go and take a look
at this. And oh, would you look at that?
It worked.
So now I can debug what's going on. Even
though the viewer node should be able to
debug,
right?
Not quite.
Oh well. Uh I guess we can use this for
viewing.
So, we can see that the velocity
apparently is
not doing anything,
but we are setting the velocity.
So, it should at the very least Oh,
that's why.
What the hell?
Oh, that's weird.
I know why that happened, but
yeah. Yeah. No, that's quirky.
We can sample the grid, then we do that,
and then we sample the grid again, and
then we pass that version along.
Okay, let's uh give that a shot.
So, that is moving the velocity around
with everything else, but
doesn't do that.
So, I think that's where the volume
curl divergence
and stuff would occur cuz if I did that
Oh, whoa. What the
I caused an explosion.
H I should probably figure out what curl
actually does. So, great curl. The
magnitude and direction
of circulation of a directional vector
grid. The magnitude and direction. How
would it know the magnitude and
direction inside one vector?
Hm.
I mean, it could just be normalized, but
I thought that
h and then divergence is how much values
like low and stuff. I know I I know how
all this works 100%.
And then we scale depending on the
divergence. Or maybe that should be like
a one divided.
I do not know.
Oh, fun.
Probably didn't do anything though. We I
divide by that value. This will probably
lead to very good results. Yes. Yes.
Yes. As we can see.
Uh let's try this one.
H.
Quirky. Quirky
merge.
But actually, no, that should be just
fine.
No, we do need to sample the Okay, this
is even this is weird even for me to
wrap my head around just because like
grids
it's very different from geometry
because these grids are kind of separate
from it.
It's weird. It's very weird.
If I think of them like instances, like,
oh, here's a grid instance. It makes
more sense
or like lists. It It's weird. It's
weird. H
[Music]
Let's see. Hey, I want I'm watching from
the start, not live. I want to say that
by default SDF grids and density grids
are sparse in all this. Fox grid is good
for making dense grids. Ah, okay. I I
did
kind of assume that after I saw a few of
the errors. So, in this case, uh the
grid is voxalized, but you'll you're
still back in time. You'll you'll make
it here soon enough.
Let's see. So we got that.
So again, the divergence is that
all wait a minute. I
can I just
I have a material here and take a look
at the attributes as a volume. Does that
actually work?
Please ignore the duplicates right
there. Uh actually wait. Um volume Um,
principled volume. Let's take a look at
that. Ignore the double up right there.
Here we go. Uh, so the density is the
density and then the color will be that.
So if we take a look at this in theory,
we'll see
something.
Here's the emission emission strength.
Ah, no, nothing appears. density.
[Music]
I forgot how to reference
grid data
cuz here that's not showing anything.
And this is the Oh, wait. No, that's
just material.
No, that should in theory work. H
Rune will collapse any homogeneous areas
into single tiles, making it sparse
again. Yes, that is good to know.
[Music]
See,
so let's reattach this so that I can
view this again. I'm very new to this. I
have no clue what I'm doing, but I think
it'll be fun. Probably. Probably.
Um
Oh, wait. Was the reason
Oh, did it not show up because there was
literally nothing there?
A uh
is anything there?
Let's go back to the material and get
the principled volume.
I have a feeling this will Oh, yeah.
Nope. That is actually showing up. Now,
let's see if I can actually pull the
attributes
like the emission strength. No. Dang. I
forgot how to actually
reference that.
Input
attribute bevel. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Object info particle
point color tangent texture coordinate.
No.
Object instancer view layer. Nope. That
doesn't make any sense.
Um,
but there must be a way. I remember
there's color, which is that.
So, I'm assuming that the color would
just be
a default value. Maybe the name is just
Now, hear me out here. color maybe.
Wouldn't that be crazy?
Um,
let's see.
I'm so excited about join bundles being
a Oh,
yeah.
Huh. I Oh, that's so cool. I remember
saying a while back, "Oh, I kind of wish
there was a join bundle now that Oh,
they I highly doubt that they heard that
from me, but I'm I'm glad that they
added it." It's cool to see cuz yeah,
joining bundles like again bundles
depending on like my understanding of
their implementation may be the most
overpowered thing that we'll be getting
in Geonodes going forward, at least for
general management of stuff,
especially with simulations. But yes,
this will be quite nice for doing that.
But that's uh like the simulation stuff
is in the future.
So if there is a color
like vector is not like how do we access
grid info? I know I have a feeling it's
possible beyond just color.
Okay. So, let's go and store named grid.
And we'll make this one color.
Make that one a Oh. Oh, we have our
vectors. Okay, no biggie. Um,
I guess we could just uh do that. And it
works. Okay, my gut was correct.
Just name it color and it will appear.
Cool. Cool. Nice.
and negatives are showing up as I
expected. So, let's go to the shader
editor and normalize.
Wait, actually, let's check
color does that appear there? Oh, that
does appear there. Wait, then what about
Vel? Oh, Vel also. Huh?
Wait, why did that?
Huh?
Did I just not have this correctly um
stored before? Okay. Well, that's how
you do it.
Why did it not work before?
Oh, is it because of the emission color?
Oh.
Huh.
Lovely.
Um, well, I guess I'll go and normalize.
[Music]
Okay. So, I just didn't have the
emission strength on, which does sound
like me, but it it I think there's a
little bit more going on here
cuz uh that should not occur.
01.
No, there there there's some issues
going on.
So, it's at least not entirely my fault.
Or maybe just the data I'm sampling is
just so out of whack that uh it just has
an aneurysm.
[Music]
I don't know.
Let's also abs this uh absolute
then scale. The new square nodes are
growing on me even though they do take
up a little bit more space.
Mhm.
Quite quirky.
But anyway, um
let's just have that one as ah.
So, let's go. Oh, wait. Was it that I
used get names grid and remove is on by
default?
Ah, that's probably what happened.
Okay, because again, these are like
instances. So, this would be like get
instance and it would remove it from the
original so that there wouldn't be a
copy. I think I might be possibly
beginning to understand
what is occurring at this time.
You I still do not understand.
[Music]
Let's take a look at you.
Cool. Cool.
Still not entirely sure what's going on,
but hey.
[Music]
most intriguing.
And also these can be sparse volumes
which Oh, that's why the devs were using
these as colliders
because we can in theory use these for
well I could try that right now. Wait a
gosh darn second. Let me save this in
its current state so that I don't lose
such valuable progress.
So, okay, this is going to be weird if
it works, but bear with me. Bear with
me. I'm going to have a new thing right
here
to SDF
to SDF grid.
So, if we do this, this should turn this
into a grid.
And then
uh volume
I can't spell for the life of me today.
That's nothing new. So SDF grid. So we
need to store nope. Store named grid. So
there are no volumes here. So we need to
make a volume kind of. This will just be
a density.
And then we need another one for the
normal.
Wait a minute. We can use the
mesh.
Oh no. Uh volume
sample
gradient.
Will that give us the normal
uh The gradients
direction in magnitude of the change in
values
divergence is that so probably not but
maybe
circulation of a direction. So this I
think is my best shot.
Um
but hey, here's hoping. So this will be
normal.
So we have that and then if we have
let's say a ton of points around in the
scene
random value if I can get the hang of
this then I can create so many
possibly interesting things potentially
SDF
um collision.
So if I do this and then I sample
uh
sample grid,
we do this and then we get the said
grid. We might not even need that.
This is probably a terrible, horrible,
absolutely atrocious idea,
but it might work.
90 oh 9.4 24 milliseconds already. That
is uh not a good sign.
If Oh, it's Yeah, it's mainly just
because of that. Okay, so with that, it
should
be moving the points out of the way.
So,
if I were to throw these in a sim zone,
in theory,
and if I were to bake the grids, that
might work as well.
Uh, so let's have this and then also
have a velocity step. These are custom
node groups I made. Make stuff like this
easier to do.
Go. We plug that into there. We plug
that into there. Take a look at the
outputs. So, in theory,
just these should do collision.
They're doing collision. Oh my gosh.
Maybe not the best collision cuz I
assume that this might not be normalized
properly
though in this case. Let's uh just get
you. Even though No, it should be
normalized either way because that's how
I set it. Nope. Wait a minute. Did I
make it so that the normal was not
normalized in here?
It's not.
That is a safeguard I should have put in
anyway. Well, uh yeah, no, it's fine.
So, right now with just a few nodes, uh
let me join the original geo.
Uh join geometry.
We can see that a volume is indeed being
Oh, it's not coarse enough.
So, let's do this and then run a prune.
No, it's an SDF grid, so it can't be too
pruned. Is this live or pre-recorded?
This is pre-recorded. I anticipated your
comment from 8 hours in the future.
Let's see.
[Music]
Sir, you are hacking a vection. Lol.
This will be easier when that lands.
Yes, to the person in the past, yes, I
am hacking it completely.
Totally horrible idea. Um, but again, I
I know I can do it. I just need to
People have done invection in the past.
I just don't have that in my memory at
the moment. So now if I do this, they
will sit on top because I took the
radius into account. So we don't even
need U or U or U. All we need is U and
U. So
grid gradient. Maybe this should be grid
normal or I'm assuming this is like
using OP open BDB terminology. So that's
probably the way it's supposed to be
referred to.
Cool.
How about that?
You love to see it. Oh, just a few.
Yeah. No, that is surprisingly okay.
That was surprisingly easy. So, if you
treat grids
Oh, let me also put that uh right. If
you treat grids like instances or
layers, it makes a lot more sense. So,
let me go and get you place this right
here. So, this will be a nice floor.
Oh, would you look at that? though we
can see that. Uh oh, wait.
55 milliseconds. Oh my gosh.
Wait, what is causing 55 milliseconds?
Is it because of the
prune? I would imagine.
Oh, yeah. No, it's it's the prune.
if I Well, no, of course rotating won't
do um anything
because of stuff. So, I need to go into
edit mode to do that. But yes, getting
Okay, so if we do that and then play it
again and then we can move this around.
That is
pretty good, got to say.
Well, why is that causing it to lag? Oh,
wait. That's because of you.
Ah, that explains a lot.
Okay, so let's turn the bounce down to
zero. They'll just fall and not do
anything. If we turn it up all the way,
they will just bounce into infinity.
Well, almost infinity because, well, my
implementation of friction and all that
was perfect. No problems whatsoever.
Yeah. Uh-oh.
Oh, those fell because they're literally
underneath the uh Yeah, there we go. You
love to see it. And if I added in
particle self collisions, well, then
that would work.
In theory,
I could do particle self collisions
because I can turn the volumes that the
particles themselves into a grid. H
um
that might be a horrible idea, but let's
skip to go. Okay, so points to SDF grid.
This is the worst idea that I've had,
but it will work. Or wait, do SDF grids?
It'll be fine. Let me save this because
I do not anticipate that it will be fine
here.
[Music]
Well, that's just about as good as I
could have expected.
Yeah. And the radius we need to make
sure that's the actual radius.
[Music]
Oh, almost working.
Or wait a minute, because it's a radius,
but that's as an SDF grid. I need to see
the SDF grid.
Crap.
[Music]
Okay. Voxil side. Oh, this is actually
very potentially very very bad.
I'd have to because once these get too
big,
it'll get really really bad really
really fast.
But we can if we look closely here and
see that that part is working. So this
would have to be very low for it to
actually function.
But we can see that these their
collision parts are there. This is a
very very bad idea.
Oh no, they're colliding with
themselves. What am I talking about?
Of course they're doing that. They're
colliding with their own geo.
So, how could I possibly make it so that
they ignore themselves?
Well, I could always No, that wouldn't
work either.
Herm,
[Music]
how could I make that actually work?
Maybe
if the gradient is less than a certain
amount, then don't do anything
potentially.
Crap.
This can completely lag and freeze at
any moment. Just to let you all know.
Let me go and uh multiply this by like
0.1 so that we can see what's actually
going to occur here. So here, yeah,
they are colliding, but yeah, the the
previous point still stands.
So I could Oh, wait. I could make it so
that they're just attracted to
Yeah. No, I could do that. Okay, so
let's go and play around with this. So
we'll put the sign distance into there,
but instead we're going to set this to
be negative. So they're attracted to
each other instead of repulsed.
I thought that would have been a little
bit better.
Or actually, wait, let's just
Oh, wait. Yeah, no, we just need to set
velocity.
Okay, so we'll ignore collision spread.
Oo, that's nice. Uh, we'll ignore that
for now. And we're just going to get the
normal
scale it by this and then plug it in and
th this will be our force. So in theory
we remove you as well.
Set this to be negative. No, but this
won't work either. This can't work
because of the
radius issue. All of them will be inside
their own radi and they can't sample any
other ones. So completely ignored what I
just said. Yeah. No, this this can't
work.
Uh okay. So let's just ignore that and
go back to square one, which wasn't a
bad square to be on if if I had to
guess. Not a bad square, but just a
square. There we go. So back to here. We
have the volumes. They're colliding. So
if we wanted actual collisions to
happen, we would basically have to run a
parallel
like fluid simulation. So I would have
to add vect. But you know,
yeah. So yeah, volumes can be used for
collisions, which SDFs are used for
collisions in various circumstances.
Like I believe Unreal Engine's Lumen
uses it for like light stuff. I would
have to double check on that. But stuff
like uh ray marching for like um
radiance cascades and stuff like that,
SDFs are very very useful. So having
kind of a native SDF thingy mob hopper
is good. And also my SDF collision asset
works even though grids did not exist
when I made it. So I was thinking ahead.
The math checks out.
Um yeah
um
bandwidth
with active voxil service.
Let's change that to one.
[Music]
I'm not sure what that does.
It looks like
at least having more than one
is better.
I would assume if this is sparse, which
I assume it is by default.
Yeah,
it does that. And we only care about the
negative part of the SDF
for collisions, even though the positive
one could be used in other situations.
[Music]
But yes, this is
quite intriguing,
I want to say.
Okay. Um
la dah.
That's that. Also, let's go and
randomize the um the points radi
just so that we can see that the
different radi
Ohoh.
Why would that Oh, wait. I think I know
why that's happening. We can see it
works unless the radius is too big,
which I assume is because it's colliding
with multiple surfaces at the same time.
Substeps would fix that. or it's just
like trying to fall through the floor,
which in this case that's because
they're just moving way too fast. Well,
if I did that, none uh none should fall
through the floor. But we can see it's
still still having a few issues. Maybe
they're like colliding with that and it
has trouble.
I don't know.
Plenty of room for error,
but we'll deal with that when it gets
there.
Or maybe just the SDF is not quite as
accurate as I think because this has a
very low margin for error.
No, that wouldn't make sense.
But yeah, we got that. Let's go and make
this lean over so that we can see them
all fall. We're at 46 minutes. The time
just flew by.
But actually, yeah, why is that
happening right there?
Is it treating the radius like a
diameter
or no?
No. I I don't know why it's kind of
hovering there.
What happens if the normals were
inverted? That could be bad.
What does this deal with high poly
meshes? Because with just a few cubes,
this is very high poly.
So, if I were to subdivide it a lot,
let's see how bad it can get.
[Music]
How many polygons is this?
Far as I've seen, performance on this
has been quite good. Okay, so that is
100,000.
[Music]
Then that's like that. Okay, so it does
scale up quite a bit.
That is to be expected. Okay.
I guess it's because yeah, no, that that
is completely expected. It's like doing
it for points on all this. So maybe in
these cases having just regular um
sampling for the SDF would be good, but
there is a point when like there's a
ratio of particles where calculating the
SDF is better than the alternative. So,
if I had like a bajillion points,
let me go and just uh undo some of the
damage I did to this.
It would be faster to sample the grid
than that. So, let's go and do 10,000
particles. That'll be fine. Oh, yeah.
Look at that.
Well, no, that's 10,000 particles. Let's
go 100,000.
100,000 particles. It's fine. Yeah, look
at that.
That's good. Uh, actually, let's make
sure that's an actual Yeah, know that's
correct. So, 100,000 particles just
fine. 1 million. This will lag. Hey, 1
million particles.
That's actually not bad.
All running on the CPU just because we
can go and sample the uh mesh grid.
Let's go and add in some more bounce and
a little bit of friction. Maybe
randomize it a bit.
One bajillion. What if I made it a
billion particles?
So, if I Let's do a speed comparison
test. So, SDF.
Uh, no. EF.
So, if I were to do this, prepare
yourselves.
This will be horrendously slow.
There we go. See, we're getting a nice
crisp three frames per second. So,
that's considerably better.
Almost like a five times speed
improvement around that
or four.
Yeah, it's because it's not doing a BBH
on this again and again and again.
It's already been converted to a grid
and then all that happens. And we could
make the grid even more sparse which
will affect um actually no that's
actually not affecting performance all
too much. Not bad. Not bad. And also
this is recalculating every single frame
and everything.
So
yeah, not bad.
Let's throw this onto the bounce so that
we have a random there. Let's set to be
between 0.5 and 0.1.
Yeah, quite a few. But let's make the
radius significantly smaller so that we
can see all the Oh, that's a lot of
that's more particles than I thought.
[Music]
You love to see it.
Attributes. Let's have some uh just, you
know, some general velocity going on.
Let's have this be noise texture. And
this is Oh, right. I made this with
delta time in mind. Man, node groups are
amazing.
Right there. So many particles the bit
rate probably can't even keep up with
it. But for like uh SDF or for self
collisions, you know, every
particle-based water sim uh uses like a
a volume simulation on top of that. So
once that happens, I can drive particles
with sim and that'll be quite cool.
We can see that the voxil uh grid is a
little bit iffy there. So I can probably
just turn up the resolution.
We can see here that performance does
not is about the same. I think sampling
these volumes, even if they're not
sparse, is uh
quite a bit uh rather efficient.
Yeah, it just has problems with sharp
corners, which is to be expected though.
If we did nearest neighbor, that make it
faster. Ah, no. Because that is sampling
just the actual nearest thing. But try
linear is the way to go.
Let's turn on cavity
world. Turn it up. There we go. Now we
can see just how dense all these
particles are. What if I try 10 million?
Well, it was nice knowing you guys. I'll
see you later.
Takes 31 milliseconds just to generate
that many.
2,500 milliseconds. Okay.
All right. Let's uh let's advance one
frame. See how long it takes. So, it
takes around
3 seconds per frame for 10 million
particles.
For Blender standards,
not bad. Well, I guess for just CPU
standards, not bad.
So, this is it with mesh collisions. 10
million of them running at a round one
frame per 3 seconds.
Now, if this were on the GPU, you would
expect this you would like this would be
real time like in Touch Designer and
stuff like that, but that's because the
GPU is specifically made for doing lots
of little things in parallel. Although
CPU again, I I forget how many cores I
have on my thing, but this is doing I'm
giving my CPU a very very hard time
right now. So, I would not recommend
doing this normally. So, let's go back
to sanity
and just have 1 million particles.
It's pretty good. Let's also get the SDF
mesh again because I just want to see
how bad it can be.
Oh, yeah. And there uh node groups are
now packed. Love to see it.
Normal. Uh wait, let's just connect this
here and here as it was
up here.
Oh, performance isn't as bad as I
thought it would be,
but it's still quite a bit faster here.
Yeah.
Look at that. Let's go and rotate this a
bit more so that we can just see it all.
So, let me double check.
Ah, a few of these are falling straight
through. So, I probably either
this grid gradient is not doing what I
expect, which is kind of what I expect.
[Music]
I assume that I did something wrong
here. Or wait. Oh, wait. Maybe this is
it. Could have done that beforehand.
and also after just to make sure.
Ah, no. Okay, so I'm assuming this is
incorrect
is causing that to happen, but at the
very least it's kind of doing stuff in
some scenarios.
The collisions seem to be fine unless
they're moving quite fast.
Yeah. Okay. Uh, that's good enough. So,
let's go and bring it down to 10,000
particles. Or is that 1,000? That's
10,000.
Isn't your computer on fire? Ah, because
volumes
01.1.
Yeah, that works. Okay, let's go back to
you. So, I do need to figure out
adection though. All in all, the
invection node will probably come along
within the next couple of days, assuming
it makes it into 5.0, which given how
many nodes were approved, I think that's
on the way.
But yes,
okay,
I think that might be everything for
today. So again, what I learned now is
you need to treat these like each grid
is its own thing.
and multiple grids can be packed into a
volume.
So grids it it is a bit confusing to me.
So grids are the volume data and you can
pack multiple
amounts of that data into one volume.
But these grids can have different
densities, different transforms,
different orientations.
So basically
grids are almost like their own geometry
type in the same that instances are
maybe not quite not really but you can
see my line of logic if I had oh right
there is the annotate tool. I was like
if I had my pen connected but no I could
just use my mouse. So here is the main
geometry line and then the grids are
just like that. Just little sub things
are attached kind of like a bundle I
guess.
And I guess lists will run in the same
way where you can potentially pack lists
into geometry lines. So you can just
have a geometry with a ton of those
packed into there. And I guess you can
already do that with cons. No.
No. I do not know why I'm talking about
with that.
though
I did hear something about packing
data into geometry bundles
actually. Yeah, let's take a look at
that. Let me take a look at the change
log. There is a lot to go over today. Uh
combine separate join bundle.
Yes. And it allows overwriting existing
values in a bundle. Oh, that's cool.
Um, bundles are also available for
shader nodes, which is good. There's
closures.
The viewer got an upgrade. All right, UV
tangents, but I think I went over that.
So, again, we finally have UV tangents.
I remember it might have been a
might have been like maybe over two
years ago where I first showed my own UV
tangent node because I have been using
that for years. But now we have one that
actually uses the proper uh MC Espace
library. So I'll match the shader editor
one to one. And there's also a fast mode
which is four times as fast.
Uh and there's an essentials library
which
um
normals. Oh, there multiple smooth
angles here.
Why is that happening? Maybe it's some
duplication stuff that's being worked
on.
Um, okay. So, there's generate. Oh, and
there's dup. Why are there duplicates
here?
I only have one project saved with that.
Maybe that's why there might be some
duplication stuff happening.
Um, let's see. There should be some
new utilities in here if they're already
a part of it. Ah, here. Yes, vector. All
of these are node groups as we can see
here. There's a lot of that kind of
stuff. Tons of new node groups.
Spherical. So, this turns cartisian into
spherical coordinate coordinates and uh
cylindrical coordinates. Do these also
apply to the shader editor? But you
could just copy them over. So, yeah,
it's fine. Text. No, nothing there. Hash
value. So yeah, nothing there.
This is becoming quite big at the
moment.
Um
[Music]
yes,
random rotation.
Yeah, there's some duplication happening
which is a little odd. We look inside
here. Yep, that seems accurate. turning
into rotation.
Wait, is that a new node?
Since when has quat turning into
rotation been a thing? Wait,
quad turning to rotation? No, that's
Have I just Wait, did that exist before?
Wait. Uh,
[Music]
no. Wait, did that always exist? Did I
just miss that? Wait, I need to check
4.5 real quick.
Let me go and check that. Hello. We have
31 people here. Welcome to the end of
the stream or I'm just doing some other
stuff. So, Quatian Oh, wait. Was that
added in
Oh, quater inter rotation did exist in
4.5. Did I just miss that?
If I knew that, I would have been
playing around with that a bit more.
How about that?
What? Let's see. Let me check the 4.5
change log.
Uh, quanternian.
No, nothing in there. Maybe it's been
around for a lot longer.
H.
Anyway,
that is intriguing.
Did I miss a node? I thought I knew
every single node that existed.
Uh, okay. So, back to
volumes, which why why are you going
down?
Uh, you should be going
up.
Oh, no. The velocity is being set and
doing weird stuff. So, I'm going to just
chop this out for the or just not apply
it for the time being
and that part right there.
[Music]
And mute you as well.
Oh, that's why. That explains a lot.
accidentally connected the wrong one
into there, which is why
Yeah, just space it out a little bit.
So, this being right there,
again, it's not actually adection,
[Music]
but it's kind of cool. I would need to
use the divergence and all that to make
that work. And also, this will work in
two dimensions as well.
Oh. Ah, yes we can do a one degree of
Wait, can we do Oh, no. We can't do one
with less than
it has to have two voxels. Interesting.
Interesting. We can't have a grid with
less than or the volume cube cannot do
one with just one, but I assume that we
can create one that is
that doesn't have that. I'm assuming
that's a former limitation that no
longer applies
if I had to guess.
The only way to make that is with volume
cube.
[Music]
So
h there is most definitely a workaround
for that.
Ah it's because of that right.
So 2D I know Houdini again I haven't
been in Houdini for a while and I should
be in there but uh Houdini supports like
two dimensional volumes
and I think we can go and do that as
well.
But yeah know this will be this will be
interesting. We'll be cooking up some
new uh simulation stuff with this.
Quite interesting.
right here. We can just see the whatever
this is going about. Let's also go and
uh set shade smooth
though. I still again if this was trial
we can see that it really likes to
disappear on us.
Yeah. So, nearest nearest neighbor is
okay.
This is quite interesting.
Let me go and get a nice camera set up
here because I'll probably post this
tomorrow.
Yeah.
Make it look nice and fancy, you know,
have a black background.
Then have that as well.
And then to make it actually look really
nice, I just need to throw on an
emission color. Crank it up a bit. And
then uh let's go and and filmic. Oh, a
few other things.
Uh
I got it confirmed what I think was a
community developer that the video
sequence editor is currently only CPU
for
uh the modifiers. So, the compositor
modifiers, but they're looking into
getting it to work with the GPU. Uh, not
for 5.0, but in the future, which is
cool to hear. It being cached helps
quite a bit. So,
let's do that. Go back to geo nodes. Go
and get it to be all white. Oh, yeah.
Turn down the saturation
norm. It is normalized already, right?
Something doesn't seem right.
It's too saturated. Shouldn't be that
saturated though. I guess there's always
AGX,
which is so desaturated. But actually, I
could go and pull
my
aces thing, but that goes and messes
with the bloom quite a bit.
We could just do the bloom before
That could work quite well. Yeah. Let's
go over to standard and I'm going to
pull my ASUS color transform node group
uh file append. Let me try to ah yes
it's right here. Uh node tree
as cinematic. Yes. Let's go back to the
compositor.
So uh TM is cinematic. Let's apply that
beforehand. Go into the geo node tab.
Take a look at it. We should see
the bloom is not working as I intended.
So, if I do this in post,
[Music]
we'll see. Oh, wait. No, that that's
what I was supposed to do. Accidentally
put beforehand.
Uh, let's go back to comp. Take that
out. Right. Because the color transform
always has to be does has to be done
before the bloom, I think.
Although, wait, why does it work?
Oh, no. Wait, that makes sense. Yeah,
bloom happens before the color
transforms. I had that wrong before.
Makes a lot of sense.
Here, I could just do some really funky
stuff.
Although
let's go back to the geo node editor and
is this actually affecting nope that is
affecting that. So if I were to scale
the velocity offset by negative one
[Music]
actually no
we need to
wait
I need to wait how do I do this again I
need to set the velocity and then apply
the velocity afterwards. So in this case
it would be more like this.
So
oh my brain is really really straining
right now.
We don't need to do field to grid. I
don't think what we need to do is
get the named grid my brain. Oh I can
feel the gears in my brain just
completely halting at the thought of
this. do that
and then we get this
and completely break everything.
We take that out. We take that out. We
get the position. We plug that into
there. And then we plug you hopefully
into here and it doesn't break
everything even though it does.
What's going on, buddy?
But it expects a field or a singular
value.
I know it shouldn't because I've done
this before.
The position.
Um.
Yeah. No, but it's a sample. Wait.
Oh,
that just not needed.
I I think I I think I royally royally
screwed up.
Set that to be zero.
Mhm. Yep. Nope. Just disappears.
Completely expected.
Yep.
I don't know what I expected, but that
was one of them.
H
Mhm. Yep. Seems good. Seems good to me.
A field or a singular value. But wait,
what did I screw? Wait, let's check the
reference.
We have that D and that's fine, but it's
not referencing a grid, which may be the
key.
[Music]
So,
I need to use like a grid to field.
Let's delete you so that it doesn't
confuse me anymore. This is complicated
stuff.
So wait, we have the grid and then we
have grid feeding into that which we
actually wait
[Music]
that doesn't want to connect to there.
But did I screw up?
It's not like that. then everything's
fine
because it's a field. But a grid is a
singular value. So I would have to oh
right I would need to sample the grid
and
have the position which I assume that's
the default but anyway and most likely
this conversion layer is not needed
but
eh
and that's not moving at all
but it's acting as if it is fracturing
it into a tiny little a ton of tiny
little chunks.
So, we get it,
we sample it, and then we put it back.
So, yes, this conversion layer is most
likely not needed at all, but it's the
only way I know it.
And that
the noise scale is zero but it's giving
a noise pattern which means that
ah that explains a lot.
So we need to keep this low very low. Ah
there we go.
[Music]
Lovely.
Almost uh Conway's game of lifeish.
[Music]
Interesting.
Most interesting.
I don't know what it is, but hey, if it
looks cool, I'll take it. So, we can
have some initial velocity right here
and then make it move.
I think just for making my brain a
little bit better, I'm going to
not. But we do need to voxilize the grid
beforehand.
So yeah,
I created acid.
Oh, that acid.
Yeah, I guess so.
Remember kids, don't do drugs.
Uh, we could have that, which is
interesting,
though. No, I think normalized looks a
bit better.
Bit of glow.
And who knows, we could uh throw in some
weird compositing stuff just to make it
look all nice and fancy glare. Let's use
the new um sunbeams.
Ah, yes.
Yep.
You love to see it.
Maybe a bit more.
I know that's too strong.
And then what about a lens dis? Yeah,
let's just really cook this big time.
Lens dispersion.
Ah. Oh,
you love to see it.
Ah. Yes.
[Music]
H.
Everyone loves chromatic aberration.
Hear people love it when you put it in
games.
[Music]
That is a very interesting
look into that.
All right. This loses volume because of
the um
the the thingy.
Uh what was I talking about?
Uh let's also Yeah, let's have this be
ghosts instead. Strength.
modulation. Oh, yeah. No, that that
works quite well.
Uh, and if we turn the strength up, it's
just like, oh yeah, really just make
them trip.
Yeah. Now that that's the good stuff
right there.
I just got a warning. Heads up. We
detected audio in your stream belonging
to someone else. The stream may be
temporarily blocked.
Ah,
I guess apparently this isn't uh
royalty-free music. I thought it was. H
Well, anyway, temporary temporary stream
nonetheless.
Um,
yeah, it'll be up for a little while,
but yeah,
[Music]
you subdivide the grid more. Yes, but it
will start to slow down.
Let's set this to be 150. This will not
be fun.
Again, we're doing stuff that people
usually
like to do on the GPU just because
again, this is probably millions of
well, maybe a million actually. Wait, we
have 150 cube. Uh, let me get my
calculator out. What is What is 150
cubed? 15 to the power of
square root. Come on. Come on. Uh 150 to
the Where is the power of inoft
calculator?
Uh graphic. Nope.
Desmos
actually. No.
Anyway. Oh, wait. No. I have the proper
calculator.
No.
Ah, Microsoft Mathematics.
I used this in school and it hasn't let
me down once compared to the other
calculators. Okay. 150 to the power of
three. That is 3,375,000
voxels.
Yeah, that that's that makes sense.
Makes sense.
[Music]
In case you ever want to save a stream
with copyright music, you can isolate
your voice in Dinci Resolve
automatically. Don't know if it's studio
only version though. Uh yeah, I I don't
really care too much about
if the stream gets like I
I had a feeling that this song has
gotten copy copyright claims before, but
I assumed it was one of those like fake
copyright bots, but apparently maybe I
was wrong.
Um, but yeah, I I knew that going in. I
just wanted different music from the
Zelda one that I've been using for the
past 15 million years.
Yeah, that's what uh this looks like
with more voxels.
And it's only a resolution of 150x 150x
150, which I guess is a testament to
just uh how expensive voxels are just
because of it being cubed.
All right. Uh, so yeah, we still got
that. That's still going. I think that
is a good place to
end the stream cuz I've been delaying.
We're almost at an hour and 20 minutes.
That is uh a bit too long. I got stuff
to do.
Yeah. And also
I can h can I do? Yeah, I can actually.
If I store this as a velocity value
uh on here and export this as an olympic
and then bring it back in. Actually,
will cycles read this as let me save
this beforehand.
Edit preferences add-ons. Cycles you in
here? Ah, yes. It's a full build, so
cycles is around.
[Music]
Oh no. If Yeah. No, I'm not going to do
the colonels now. That'll take too long.
In theory, if I run then
[Music]
ah that's why
uh I think scale or divide this by 24.
But no, there's no motion blur at the
moment. It's not even enabled. Is it
just not
working? Where motion blur? Come on,
buddy. Um, you can store the velocity
and then the motion blur would work,
but
right now I can't even see the thing
here.
GPU is not available. Okay.
Uh, I'm assuming that's just because
this is a build.
Uh, preferences. Come on, buddy.
Yeah. No, I'll look into that later.
Oh my god. Well, that's the end of the
stream, everyone. I hope you all
enjoyed. Blender just straight up
crashed.
Um, yeah, I'm assuming that's just
because of a build. But thank you all
for watching. I hope you all enjoyed a
little look into this. Again, the
adction node is probably on the way and
that would make uh simulations a lot lot
faster.
So, like it would make volume
simulations a lot easier to do. I think
right now they are possible, but I'm
just I don't know. I forgot how to do
them. So, thank you all for watching and
I'll see you all next time. Have a good
one.